balbina gracias a ustedes y vamos
precisamente a hablar de la región
méxico es uno de los países de mayor
riesgo para ejercer el periodismo quien
silenciar a la prensa y por qué
bueno quien silencia la prensa y porque
en méxico específicamente quienes
silencian a la prensa en más del 60% son
funcionarios públicos después le sigue
el crimen organizado y siguen también
líderes sociales entonces esa es la
cifra porque porque los periodistas se
han atrevido a denunciar la corrupción
las violaciones graves a derechos
humanos en los rincones últimos del país
donde donde no llega nadie más que los
periodistas esto es algo que hemos
observado a lo largo de todos los años y
asimismo la impunidad es una
característica de los crímenes que se
registran contra periodistas y le
pregunto existe voluntad política para
esclarecer estos casos
bueno hasta este momento no lo es no
hemos visto esta voluntad que se se
concrete en acciones auto específicas
por parte del gobierno y eso es lo que
queda pendiente este gobierno todavía
tiene la oportunidad del libro de andrés
manuel lópez obrador de demostrar en los
años que le quedan los últimos tres años
de su gobierno que hay voluntad para
hacer retroceder la inmunidad en los
asesinatos de periodistas y en las
desaparecidos bueno y entretanto de
américa latina es además la región del
mundo más peligroso para ejercer el
periodismo porque en su opinión
bueno américa latina' hace rato que está
registrando altos índices de asesinatos
de periodistas
hay una situación que se ha venido
complicando que es que en muchos países
las democracias han ido retrocediendo y
se han ido convirtiendo en dictaduras
terribles como es el caso de nicaragua
como es el caso de venezuela y que son
países donde la libertad de expresión
cada vez está más deteriorada
y para finalizar también quiero
preguntarle qué garantías son las que
necesitan el ejercicio periodístico y
que reclama reporteros sin fronteras
para que los reporteros puedan ejercer
su labor libremente y no convertirse en
víctimas de la violencia y de los
conflictos que cubren
bueno en primer lugar lo que reportaron
sin fronteras está exigiendo este 2 de
noviembre es poner fin a los crímenes en
contra de periodistas en américa latina'
fin a la impunidad
si esto fuera posible lo que los
periodistas necesitan es libertad para
hacer su trabajo día